i i'm i'm
very interested to know how to so you
lived in new york right right how do you
then go from living in new york to being
like all right i'm going to start
drawing arrow manga in japan like how
does that how is that the transition
that happens well i've always been
drawing right right so like and you know
when you're a kid you want like i want
to go up and i just want to draw right
yeah
and after college i'm like okay how do i
do that
right right and like i could i could
start in the u.s but then you know
there's a comics industry and it's kind
of like it's it's
kind of uh
what i'm like but it's it's never you
know what i'm saying yeah yeah you have
to do with this sort of work yeah right
and if you want to like vent off it's
like really minor it's like super
underground yeah yeah you know just like
a very porn section but it's like
that's how you make money right
exactly you want to be friends they're
loaded dude
japan it's like this huge and like back
then like
uh mid-2000s
there was hardly any download like manga
yeah all right there's like dl site
maybe and that's about it
so i'm like
that's a low bar to
just upload stuff and like you know
solid and like [ __ ]
yeah
yeah yeah it's great i mean i guess it
was like the closest to having like an
independent scene where you could just
easily upload and just you know kind of
get your work out there instead of like
having to go through like so many
publishers and getting picked up and
stuff like that
and i guess like a good way to like grow
organically as well right because like
those kinds of works are just spread by
word of mouth yeah so you're always able
to speak japanese is it oh i had to work
on it i'm not okay i spoke it yeah but i
couldn't like really write too well
you know and if you ever saw those like
i don't know if you read like a bad
translation you know i'm talking about
yeah yeah you know it's like bad
translation
i have to so i you know spent a lot of
time like just playing uh video games
and like reading novels and stuff
research just research
helped me out you know yeah so you were
doing it
have you always been self-published or
did you come to japan self-published
teams in japan self-published and then
like a publisher like picked up on it
mm-hmm okay it's like hey you want to go
on a magazine sure why not yeah yeah
awesome so like
why did you choose to be like on the
aero side of things then i've always
been interested in the ill side
like how did you get into the aerosol
yeah yeah because i feel like every like
error manga artist always like kind of
the the beginnings are always different
oh yeah right
well my beginnings were like i think my
first
um
dojin was a
planet of the apes
oh man
okay okay
[Laughter]
oh my god
wait wait is that like how did that idea
come about you were just like watching
planet of the age one day and you're
like i want to see i can make this
harder
i remember seeing a porno
that was like
a plan with the apes
like back when i was like uh like a
teenager right and i'm like it just
stuck in my head
yeah bad
i was like what the [ __ ] was that and
like it's still it was like just eating
away at me and it's like i have to draw
this and like i just put that out oh my
god planet of the gates
that's probably what it was called i
kind of this is an accurate did did it
do well did people like i did not do
well
i mean it's kind of furry but like it
was yeah
and i sold like 70 copies
i mean i'm surprised there's an audience
if you ask me how people i think would
buy one of these 70 more people than i
thought it was going to be
jesus christ i printed a thousand
copies like jesus i was gonna like print
a hundred
but then it's like if you're gonna print
a hundred it only costs like so much
more to print a thousand yeah
so what happened to these copies where
are they um
i started like they stuck with me for a
while like every time i go to a comic
con i just like put a little bit out
oh okay okay so after like you know 10
12 years like i finally got rid of all
my
background genius research now it's just
like a rare item now i'm [ __ ] kidding
i want that i want this man
that sounds incredible it's like it's
like a bonus item man again now
so how old were you when you drew this
planet of the apes oh my god like 20
something no 2023
[Music]
that's the most bizarre origin story
i've ever heard
the planet
that sounds like a meme
tell me how you got it
tell
[Laughter]
after that it's pretty standard um
this is a dragon quest
yep okay oh yeah yeah i've seen that one
the japanese favorite very popular yeah
and that's when my uh my first editor
came to me and like hey this is pretty
nice
yeah like i gotta ask like as um as an
error artist how do you choose which you
know aside from your original work how
do you decide to choose which works to
draw
porn about i guess like
did you do you go with like the
algorithm to be like okay there's like a
bunch of this is like this this is hot
right now hot commodity right now or do
you just go with whatever you're a fan
of i think like my uh
primary motivation is like
drawing stuff that i want to read yeah
yeah when isn't available
oh no okay okay like if someone drew it
i wouldn't draw it all yeah yeah yeah
it's literally the [ __ ] i'll do it
myself
well i imagine the planet of the apes
there wasn't much of a market there
you are the market
i'll create the market myself
that's awesome
you found like the 70 people that wanted
the
planet with the dragon quest like you
know there wasn't anything that i found
like satisfying enough right yeah yeah
i'm like i have to do it myself
like how do you
how i guess how do you develop the
skills to draw h manga and error manga
specifically because did you have to do
a lot of practice or a lot of research a
lot of research
research wing queen
like did you go to like art school and
stuff
uh
major in art in
um college okay right so does that but
it doesn't really help right right i
mean like i you know you learn anatomy
and like how to how to paint how to like
i mean i'd argue anatomy is quite
important in aero manga
you don't really need it
yeah but i'm like you know you know what
i'm saying is like you don't really see
arrow manga in the style of like bucky
you know it's like
it's usually like usually more more so
than anything you know like you read the
kama sutra and you're like okay i think
i kind of figured out like basic anatomy
and like basic like you know uh
positions and stuff like that the beagle
is more important than anatomy damn
that's why it's right there
put that i want to put that put that on
a t-shirt
you see some artists and you know
hips don't go that wide or like you know
boobs don't go that big that's true
that's true
but it doesn't matter because you know
that's what he's into yeah yeah yeah
like how how much do you like to stay i
guess
true to what am i trying to say here
like a human physique are you true to
the human physique oh like i have my own
preferences but like i try to you know
expand them whenever i can yeah i'd say
your style is definitely more rooted in
reality than a lot of artists i've seen
yeah
yeah i mean like you know there's a
it's a wide variety yeah like there is a
very wide range about how odd to see the
human anatomy especially in dogen
oh my god
like some artists i'm just like have you
ever seen a human in your life
like that is not that is not what humans
look like
that's what they want that's what they
want though
that's what they want man that's what
they want oh my god yeah i think the you
know obviously that metamorphosis uh you
know is one of your biggest uh series
but like uh you've had like a couple of
other like long form yeah ones as well
right like um tsf i think
yeah tsf one of atari is a big one um
there's also the dragon ball one
overhead of yours oh you've had the the
broly one yeah yeah yeah that was i have
not read that
yeah bro yeah he wrote a burley doll the
new bloody
[Laughter]
yeah it's really wholesome it's just
like broly being like oh there's this
thing called sex
and i need some help with it because he
looks like literally a 40 year old
version right yeah yeah exactly he's
literally like the 40 year old version
of dragon ball universe
[ __ ] everyone yeah yeah
yeah he knows yeah
what i expect because like in the in the
dozen he like discovers what a boner is
for the first time and he's like what is
this i don't know what this is i'm
scared
so what do i do it hurts what gives him
a boner initially
i think it was uh the chili
remember
she was masturbating and like
they were like
what is she doing
something's happening
he literally had he literally had that
reaction of like when you discover porn
for the first time it's like oh what
what's going on what's going on what the
hell yeah
world domination yeah what is this in my
pants oh my god so excited yeah i got
asked how do you what's your creative
process around coming up with like the
different concepts of you know your
different works and everything like that
do you have one or is it just whatever
sometimes sometimes an idea just comes
and you just start drawing
well sometimes i
you know
see a work of art and i'm like like a
movie or a novel or something that i'm
reading and i'm like
if there are only more sex scenes
i think we're having different
experiences watching planet
[Laughter]
it's generally the best thing i've ever
heard yeah i guess that's how like
metamorphosis is happening right like
you're probably watching like for a
journal something similar you were like
this is way too short
i need more more of this please
no one wants to see getting
see your arm getting chopped off and uh
going
think about it it's basically just was
the storyline of the main heroine right
yeah
holy [ __ ] i'm just like
i've just connected that together how
many pages was metamorphosis again like
250 something i think right it's quite
long right yeah how long would something
like that
take because i mean like it's obviously
like reading it it's like i can do this
kind of fast i do like um pretty long
chapters like 40 50 page chapters so
like i mean that was released monthly
right yeah yeah yeah so how many months
was that like a year maybe like six
months of uh storyline damn wow which is
crazy and like i don't i didn't do every
month i did like one every other month
oh yeah right right because each each uh
chapter takes maybe like a few hundred
hours of work jeez right